the news hit like an avalanche yesterday
explosive shocking the most significant
event of the year of the decade of the
century the headlines were published on
cnn nbc news abc news fox all over the
media was trending on every social media
platform people all across this land
were
shouting about it from the rooftops town
criers were announcing it in village
squares the earth-shattering news
reverberated
around the country and down through
history and across space and time demi
lovato
is changing her pronouns
again
as people magazine reports demi lovato
is opening up about her recent pronoun
change about two months after updating
her pronouns on instagram adding she her
alongside the pronouns she'd been using
since last year which are they then
labato recently spoke to host tamera dia
on the spout podcast about what led to
the decision in response to dia asking
lovato to explain the concept of chosen
pronouns like they them the 29 year old
singer songwriter said yeah so
they them is i've actually adopted the
pronouns of she her again
now if that sentence seemed to not make
any sense get ready for a bunch more
sentences that also make no sense here
is lovato explaining her decision in
more detail she of course
updates her pronouns like apple updates
the iphone and i mean both in terms of
the frequency of the updates and the
meaninglessness and redundancy of the
updates but uh here she explains why i
think
i've actually adopted the pronouns of
she her again
so for me
i'm such a fluid person that i don't
really
i don't find that i am
felt like especially last year my energy
was balanced and my masculine and
feminine energy so that when i was faced
with the choice of walking into a
bathroom and it said women and men i
didn't feel like there was a bathroom
for me because i didn't feel necessarily
like a woman i didn't feel like a man um
i just felt like a human
and that's what they them is is about
for me it's just about like
feeling human at your core
recently i've been feeling more feminine
well there you have it yesterday we uh
you know yesterday you would have been
banned on every social media platform
for calling demi she and now you'll be
banned if you don't that's how this
works and she's simply getting in touch
with her energy sometimes her energy is
balanced sometimes her energy tips
towards the feminine sometimes it's
masculine sometimes her energy is low
and she needs to plug into an outlet in
the garage for a while
now obviously none of this makes any
sense at all this is about as credible
as the four humors theory of medicine
popular back in like the middle ages and
back then they believe that a person's
physical health their mental well-being
their personality were all determined by
the balance of blood bile melancholy and
phlegm and those are the four humors and
that theory fell out of favor once the
human body and the brain were better
understood and
uh the and the existence of germs you
know was discovered
though they may have actually been onto
something on second thought as there are
lots of people in our society today who
seem to be predominantly composed of
bile and phlegm
and yet humorism was far more defensible
and credible at the time because it was
the best available theory to explain
these aspects of the human person based
on the information they had at the time
this gender identity nonsense by
contrast is a superstition invented and
propagated contrary to all of the ample
amounts of evidence that we have on hand
we know that it's nonsense and yet it
has taken over our culture all the same
now i call it nonsense and it is
but that doesn't mean that i can't make
sense of it i do in fact understand what
demi's trying to say
i i think i understand what she's trying
to say better than she does
because this is all simply narcissism
lovato has a
cornucopia of mental illnesses and
various addictions and that certainly
plays a role but mostly
this is the end result of spending
nearly every waking moment of your life
thinking about yourself obsessing over
yourself analyzing yourself and then
analyzing your analysis of yourself a
person who adopts this um i guess
lifestyle choice of narcissism
will quickly conclude that
though she can't make up her mind about
anything and though she by her own
admission doesn't understand herself in
the slightest she is certainly she knows
more interesting more nuanced more
complex more richly and beautifully uh
sketched than most other people in the
world
this is the fundamental narcissistic
assumption that serves as the basis for
everything else when it comes to gender
identity the narcissist feels
you know feels a certain way right as we
all feel different ways and and um
but they can't actually know whether
other people who share
uh the same sex feel the same way
whether this is just how people feel
but she assumes
that they don't feel as she does because
she is her you know she's not like
anyone else her feelings are different
and meaningful and profound in ways that
nobody else's are
and so she can't make do with these sex
categories that have proved sufficient
for billions of humans before her she
needs a whole new category
because she is that transcendent she
tells herself in her deluded ego crazed
mind
and this would all perhaps
be something about which we could simply
shake our heads and laugh and
and then move on
if it was a madness consigned to
drug-addled hollywood weirdos but it's
not
you know worst of all of course children
are being recruited into sharing in the
same confusion and self-obsessed misery
as demi lovato and here is where the
lovato story
does in fact have some resonance and
relevance this is why it's actually not
something that we can simply dismiss
there's something important that can be
learned from it and that important thing
is this
demi lovato
is a grown woman technically she is an
adult at least in the chronological
sense of the term
and yet she changes her gender identity
quote unquote every 45 seconds she can't
make up her mind
what she said yesterday may not have any
bearing on today
one minute her deepest truth is that
she's a non-binary pansexual
shape-shifter and uh the next minute her
truth is something else entirely
now consider
that kids are being drugged and
mutilated their bodies permanently
altered based on their own gender
identity declarations
which are somehow even more fickle and
transmutable and fundamentally
meaningless
everything is fluid everything can be
changed
except the bodies that are butchered and
poisoned based on whatever form of
identity or expression a child has
assumed at that moment
there was a video recently that went
viral which shows someone named kellen
lackhardt
a so-called gender specialist whatever
that is at kaiser permanente in oakland
admitting
that in that program kaiser permanente
children as young as 12 years old
have had their breasts removed 12 years
old listen
yeah i think folks have kind of covered
the blockers and hormones but i'll talk
about surgical care a little bit uh in
terms of masculinizing top surgery i
think 12 is the youngest who's had
surgery through our program
and in terms of general reconstructive
surgeries we haven't had anyone under
the age of 18 have
phalloplasty lymphoid plastic but we
have had a few patients
starting
15 i don't think surgery actually
happened until 16 that i've had vaginal
plastic
again girls at the age of 12
not even in high school yet
and they're having body parts
removed
we also hear that boys as young as 16 at
an age when at an age when boys in
particular are renowned for being
impetuous and impulsive and
unintentionally self-destructive
and yet at age 16 they're being
castrated
demi lovato is almost 30 years old
and she can't decide what her gender
energy is telling her at any given
moment how in god's name
can we take an adolescent
still over a decade away from their
brain being fully formed how can we take
them seriously when they make their own
declarations
a few days ago the radical lgbt group
stonewall
tweeted that according to quote-unquote
research and they never do specify what
the research is of course but just
research research shows they say
that children as young as two
can recognize their trans identity
two
adults in their 20s and 30s struggle to
understand their identities
apparently but actual babies still in
diapers sleeping in cribs
can come to realizations that escape
those approaching middle age or older
that's the point we should take away
here
and it's why we actually shouldn't
simply ignore the adult celebrities and
other adults who parade around you know
with their different identity every
other month
far from ignoring it we should be
pointing to them
we should be putting them up on banners
saying here look at this
with the message
leave our kids
out of this
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joy we're forming a cult then
all you gotta do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
dailywire.com spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
sweet baby gang